we are in vigorous agreement or groove I
agree completely
one of us has given speeches on Wall
Street for hundreds of thousands of
dollars must be a great speech I think
we should release it I'll be happy to
release anything I have as long as
everybody else does too
here it is very nothing what really is
behind that question is whether I can
stand up to Wall Street well let's have
some facts instead of some rhetoric for
a change
compare the substance of this debate
with what you saw on the Republicans
we are if elected president going to
invest a lot of money into mental health
and when you watch these Republican
debates you know why
you